good morning uh to the members of Public
Works uh time being 10:30 we are here to
exec uh five bills this
morning and before we do um I would like
to uh recess um this executive session
probably no more than 20 minutes uh so
that I have the opportunity to caucus
and I'm going to take the Republican
members to uh the committee office if we
could and when we've done that we'll
come back come back together thank you
and I'll have the Democratic members
caucus in here any last minute stuff I
know we've talked about a lot of these
bills but in case you have any FL minute
questions uh that's the time to bring
them up now okay thank you thank
you we'll be in
recess 10 minutes right
okay
back from Recess that was pretty close
on time um the time
being well eight minutes
to um we are uh we're in public works
and we are going to open executive
session on um one two three five bills
that are before us and um we will start
with House Bill 1547
requiring mileage based exit numbers on
tier one
highways I recognize uh represent voyd
Mr chairman I move interim study for
House Bill
1547 is there a
second
com also Jack pretty much same time uh
discussion you want to speak to your
motion uh
representative uh thank you Mr chairman
in in brief uh as we've heard from a
testimony from the Department of
Transportation um they are certainly
capable of making the appropriate
changes however the funding is not yet
available and it's it's going to be
inevitable at at some particular point
that we will will be making those
changes so interim study is an
appropriate motion I feel uh so that the
planning purposes from a financial
perspective can can occur in a more
presential fashion thank you thank you
um okay second does Is there further
discussion between the
committee seeing none uh motion has been
made and seconded for House Bill 147
mileage based exit numbers on tier one
highways if you're in favor of the
motion you'll signify by saying I or yes
if you're opposed nay and with that
would the clerk please call the
role thank you Mr chair representative
cluder
yes the Clerk David Mills votes
yes representative
fidi representative Newton yes
representative kazinski yes
representative
Bowen representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin I
representative
bogert yes representative Connor
yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar
hi representative Faulkner
yes representative
Newman
yes representative Eaton is not
present representative Peterson
yes representative Horgan
yes representative jurus
yes chairman mccon chairman votes
I Mr chair the vote is 19 zero in favor
of the
motion thank
you the uh the next bill consent consent
any U disagreement on putting on
consent seeing none we will will put it
on consent thank you uh representative
Jack for that
bills uh the next um exec session will
be on House Bill 1488 FN uh relative to
Hazard mitigation
funding recognize represent Boyd for a
motion Mr chairman I would move that
house bill 1488 with fiscal note be
moved to interim study second that
motion motion made and seconded
discussion uh very briefly if I could Mr
chairman I am absolutely enthralled with
this idea I think it is uh the way that
the bill was written is appropriate so I
want to thank the sponsor rep Aaron for
bringing the bill forward I did have
conversations with director buckon who's
responsible for managing the plan uh and
he said that um they would be able to
take on those particular duties um my
concern for the interim study motion is
it's an offb budget cycle request and I
I think it should be vetted directly
through the the budgetary process so
that a more thorough examination of what
the true cost of the program might be in
order for it to be effective to some of
the impacted communities that would
benefit from the program so that's the
the Genesis behind my interim study
motion thank you thank you that
represent cluder did you want to add to
that second I appreciate the committee
uh represent boy making this motion
that's why I second it because I think
this is a very important issue and I've
been working with representative uh
erron not only on for this bill but
bills that are in other communities I
know it's a bit of a complicated subject
but we really we agree that that whether
it's my community of cyon or her
community of aworth and other
communities in Sullivan County as well
as the rest of the state who has
suffered damages from the devastating
flaws we've been having because of
heavier rain we need to address this
issue because some of the towns in cyon
and aworth are about the same population
and these flaws have been so bad they
basically consumed each Town's at least
half their Highway budgets trying to fix
the problems and this is a real burden
on the communities especially since we
can't sometimes federal aid takes a long
time and it's a real pain thank you very
much for making this motion thank you uh
thank you represent cluder i' I'd like
to address something quickly and then
we'll take any other comment I during
this last winter uh during two events a
a winter and a spring event my towns and
District day four of my eight had
tremendous damage um and repairs were
made um FEMA came in and made you know
no promises but told us everyone had to
take care of their own damage and that
they would be there through the process
and if the process were to work and it
was to qualify and it only qualifies for
properties adjacent to the uh to the
highway uh it would be a year plus I
have two or three towns sitting there uh
that these will be budget Busters
there'll be no other town no other funds
are going to be used for highways if if
they're not reimbursed I'm totally in
favor of this legislation the problem is
as represent boy brought up we have
already done the budget and to open the
budget the chairman and many members on
both sides of the aisle are saying this
is not the year to open that back up so
I think I think inm study going forward
I don't think that's enough money and
I'm hoping I'm hoping when this comes
back out it'll be some sort of
compounding fund that will have uh more
money put into it as the years go by so
if I could I would be supporting this uh
I don't think it's good policy on the
second year and I too will support
intrum study any other one in the
committee would like to have
comment okay thank you so
um we will uh call the role on House
Bill 1488 FN relative to Hazard
mitigation funding if you're in favor of
the motion you'll signify by saying I or
yes if you're opposed Nay with that Mr
clerk would you call the role thank you
Mr chairman representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative
fidi representative Newton yes
representative kazinski yes
representative
Bowden representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar I
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton is not here representative
Peterson yes representative Horgan yes
representative jurus
yes chairman
mccon chairman votes I Mr chair the vote
is 190 in favor of the motion thank
you we will move excuse me should we put
this on consent
consent
let's put it on consent and see if it
goes without objection we'll put this on
consent I have a question with an FN
note on
there um but we will start there thank
you uh we'll move on to House Bill 1043
relative to Capital appropriation for
legislative parking garage design and I
believe I will recognize represent
pulner Mr chairman thank you I have an
amendment friendly technical Amendment
um you may recall in
the uh discussion we had the we
discovered that the
original Amendment submitted by the
chairman inadvertently in drafting
deleted the um effective date clause and
didn't replace it so this basically
keeps the additional language put in by
representative mak's uh Amendment the
same as it
is and renumbers what used to be the um
line two was the effective date Clause
that's now line clause three so it's
just a technical fix for a little
oversight thank you um any any questions
on the amendment before we vote give you
a chance to send it along here I I will
say while you have a moment to u to read
if you haven't seen it before I'm very
appreciative of uh uh representative
fauler for pulling this together for us
um I was I was out of this meeting I
just uh I believe I I've mentioned this
to most folks um the parking garage uh
planning is is already complete they're
going out to speak with the city I
believe next week uh to share with them
the plan U there are monies from the
past capital budget for this purpose
that they want to shift those funds back
to a capital project here in the uh in
the state house so that's what that's
about and then as you know police
training um had come in with u came in
one of their Capital budgets with a
surplus but they have an issue um in in
their building that their new boilers
don't communicate with the thermostats
so they they need to appropriate money
so they don't have to go down the hall
every day and turn systems on and off so
um if there's more monies left for that
then they this legislation will allow
them to use a previously appropriated
capital budget there's no opening the
capital budget and spend the monies
where it needs to
be so representative Farner has brought
forward amendment number
H I I will second that motion motion is
made in second
are there any discussion on the
amendment Voice vote okay thank you uh
so if you're in favor of the amendment
to House Bill 1043 is stated in
0375 uh signify by saying I and raise
your hand I I any
opposed carries
unanimously
we will now move on to
um as
amended uh House Bill
1043 uh represent
melson uh I'm sorry I move off to pass
as amended on House Bill 1043 seconded
no go ahead Vice chairman motion motion
made seconded by cluder uh as amended
house bill Bill uh 1043 relative Capital
appropriation for the legislative
parking garage design if you're in favor
of that motion signified by saying I or
yes and oppose nay or no uh with that
when you're ready Mr clerk please call
the role thank you Mr chairman
representative cluder yes representative
Mills votes yes representative
fidy representative Newton yes
representative
kazinski representative
Bowden representative Boyd Boyd V sign
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar hi
representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman yes representative
Eaton is not here representative
Peterson yes representative horon yes
representative jurus yes chairman makoni
thank you chairman votes I Mr chair the
vote is
190 in favor of aop pass as amended I am
loving this
energy with the um the last bill that we
had before us for today is that consent
also because it is not new money it's
not and uh is there any objection to
putting that on the consent
calendar seeing none we
will the last bill before us for today
is two more yes we do thank
you House Bill 1347 FN relative to yard
debris and roadside
vegetation
1379 did I miss say that
okay thank you uh recognize uh represent
Boyd for a motion Mr chairman I would
move House Bill 1379 with fiscal note as
inexpedient to
legislate is there a
second second
that uh would you care to discuss your
motion I'll make this very brief because
I know that the uh the sponsors in the
office uh in the committee room and I do
want to thank you for bringing forward
with the bill um and I certainly
appreciate and share your concern for me
personally it really comes down to how
do we enforce this and that's really the
for me that is the main concern behind
the uh behind the spirit of Bill is how
do we actually enforce this so that's
why I'm I'm I moved the uh inexpedient
to legislate thank you Mr chairman thank
you
ument Mills do you care to speak to your
second I do not at this time thank you
thank you any further discussion
represent cluder uh yeah and I think I
thank the sponsor for bringing this
forward but I just I don't know if it's
if it's a a big problem I think it's a
problem with enforcement of it and I
don't know I'm not a legal expert but
could this especially if it were doing
this against mean is this an a violation
of unfunded mandates and I'm not sure of
that but I just I I think right now we
try in most cases to take care of our
yard debris and from my experience I
mean I take from my experience and
obviously this you know so I think that
it is not necessary at the present time
now someday we might need it so I will I
frankly will vote itl on this
Bill thank you please thank you Mr
chairman represent J perhaps the U and
thank you for the bringing the bill
forward but perhaps it could use a
little tuning up I've seen it in the
neighborhood I've
seen uh you know
residents get yach clippings uh grass
clipping out into the street sometimes
it gets picked up sometimes it doesn't
it ends up in a catch Basin uh I do see
what the intent might be behind this
there may be a little more work to be
done on it though okay thank you thank
you any further
comment seeing
none um we will um call the role on
House Bill 1379 FN relative to yard
debris roadside vegetation if you're in
favor of the motion it L you will
signify by saying I if you're opposed
you will say no or or nay uh with that
when you're ready Mr clerk thank you Mr
chair representative cluder yes
representative Mills votes yes
representative
fidi I heard him that time
representative Newton yeah
representative
kazinski representative
Bowden representative
Boyd representative Melvin yes
representative bogert yes representative
Connor yes representative Jack yes
representative Abbott yes representative
Edgar hi representative Faulkner yes
representative Newman
yes representative Peterson yes
representative Horgan yes
representative jurus yes chairman mccon
chairman votes I Mr chair
the motion passes
190 would anyone be objection to consent
if
possible seeing none we will put it on
consent
now moving on to House Bill
1253 renaming the Blair State Forest and
Campton as the Jane Kellogg State
Forest um I would accept a motion by
Boyd Mr chairman I would move that house
bill 1253 be inexpedient to
legislate motion made in ex itl any
second is by Jack by representative Jack
um so boy would you represented would
you like speak to your motion yes I do
thank you Mr chairman I I think it's
worth pointing out all of us received a
lot of emails from citizens in the town
of Campton that had nothing but glowing
things to say about Jane Kellogg and the
work that she's done uh for conservation
conservation education environmental
issues in her own community and um she
certainly based on the anecdotes that
were that were sent to us which they
were joyful to read and I mean that
sincerely it's it's nice to see people
in their local community having that
kind of local impact on some of the
things that we all see here sitting up
here at a state level so I think we we
should be commending and lauding chane
kellar for the work that she's doing in
the town of Campton but what I would
also say is that there are pieces of
land that are owned by the town that may
be more befitting that may be more
visible to um promote
the legacy of Jane Kellogg that would be
befitting of the work that she's done as
opposed to a state forest that from from
all accounts is kind of tucked out of
the way and it's really you know not on
the beaten path there there there isn't
a place to park there isn't a place
where you can you know congregate and
recreate in that particular State Forest
and I think um we also learned that it's
it's still logged for you know they they
manage the the land as well with the
state so I think um and I also know and
as I've learned that the know we
generally have a history of not uh
renaming State Forest um here so um my
reason behind the nxp to legislate is
the history of of how we've handled
State Pro State forestry property in the
past um and it is not meant to be um
dismissive to the to the great work that
uh Jane Kellogg has done in the town of
Canada I want that to be publicly clear
so thank you very much Mr chairman
thank you represent boy represent Jack
did you want to add comment to your
second uh thank you Mr chairman yes I
would uh I'm confident that Jane kog is
deserving of Honor for the work that she
did on the Moose plate program uh the
committee has had a long-standing
practice of not naming artifacts of any
kind after living people we have made
exceptions to that but as a general
policy uh the committee does not do that
uh we did hear testimony that Jane
Kellogg is living uh the second uh
aspect is the state agency uh
responsible for the forest was opposed
to the bill and so I am I am comfortable
with in expedient to legislate on this
Bill thank you representative Jack
represent
pulner thank you I not going to oppose
the uh the motion just because I
understand there are some other reasons
but I did want to state that some of the
testimony we heard was that the uh
applied the state agency as the one who
should be naming
State properties and that they were the
ones who are better
than better position than than this body
to determine whether somebody's
contribution was significant enough to
the state so I just want to establish
that this is the place where people need
to come and that it's not the
prerogative of individuals in the you
state agency to decide yes or no that
this is the right right body but uh in
this case I understand the reasons
against it thanks thank you
representative for that yes represent
Newman yes thank you I'm I'm not going
to oppose the motion either I would just
point out for the committee that I
pulled up the on the the Moose plate the
website just last night for the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources in the information about the
moose plate we heard testimony that due
to Jane Kellogg's efforts 20 million was
raised the website is showing more than
30 million 20 2023 was the 25th
anniversary of the legislation that was
reported and it's still coming across
public radio um they're into the fourth
letter on the Moose plate program and I
noted that the artist the the person who
won the uh the illustration contest was
mentioned in the in the uh thing I I
don't know if their
website I would think it wouldn't need
to be legislated but maybe the
department could consider adding her
name under the information about the
school the holderness school the fourth
grade and that Mrs Kellogg was the
teacher just a suggestion just a comment
thank you thank you
representative any further
discussion thank you if you are in favor
of the motion itl how house build 1253
renaming the Blair State Forest in
Campton to the Jane as the Jane Kellogg
State Forest she signify by saying I or
yes uh if you were opposed nay or no
with that would the U clerk please call
the role thank you Mr chair
representative cluder
yes representative Mills votes yes
representative
fidi repres representative Newton yes
representative kazinski yes
representative
Bowden representative Boyd Boyd votes I
representative Melvin yes representative
bogert yes representative Connor yes
representative Jack yes representative
Abbott yes representative Edgar I
representative fauler
yes representative Newman
yes representative Peterson yes
representative Horgan yes representative
jurus yes chairman
mccon chairman votes I Mr chair the vote
is 190 in favor of
itl thank
you to the
consent
calendar
objection
okay so you're you're asking not to put
on the consent calendar represent
Fon okay no all I need is one objection
yeah regular
calendar thank you for that uh that will
um that will conclude our business today
do we want to
minority um Barry do you uh excuse me
represent F no one voted in the minori
that's true no never mind we're we're
never mind we're good thank
you uh that'll conclude our business for
today I apologize we had to come back in
but with um you know with the hour being
late um I didn't want to go handle this
last week so thank you all for being in
attendance and I believe we will see you
tomorrow and if there are any absences
on either side please let representative
cluder and myself know about tomorrow
thank you one and all thank
you all right it's a little awkward on
the nameing there if you're not there
there is an amendment that will be
circulated uh tomorrow on the Conway
Branch rail line
also